yeah when you slapped me around
yesterday I remember that I hope you're
not too hurts yo don't worry things are
going to change today
he's going down all right we ready and
ready good luck good luck uh lightning
first okay that's right they changed
today Alexa
come up please
I don't think I like that oh no are you
kidding me
wait I wasn't expecting
I'll take that why wouldn't I watch that
oh no there goes your queen how did I
fall for that that's a basic move okay
you gotta watch more YouTube videos
this is very bad a little bit he's just
doing this with two freaking pieces Mike
seriously
oh no
no much let's go again okay let me get
one more that was I gave away the whole
game it was always so fast it was
terrible it's important tricks to learn
I know that was a basic one I wasn't
even paying attention I I fell for it
when you said oh it was a mistake